if we can't trust our doctor who can we
trust
[Music]
doctors were first taught to do no harm
that we had the medical equivalent of a
serial killer on our hands
christopher dutch operated on 38
patients of those 38
33 ended up injured and two died he put
a screw
through a nerve it looked like a bomb
had gone off in my back
he introduced himself as god's gift to
spine surgery the guy couldn't operate
he was terrible he started gnawing away
at the human spine
it was like a horror movie
at least five surgeons had called the
texas medical board
christopher dench's patient is dying a
few feet from him
and he's unperturbed decisions were made
which put dr
dunches career over the patient's
interest
all i wanted was the pain to stop one of
his best friends flatlined three times
in a 24-hour period
he was effectively decapitated during
the operation
christopher dunch turned his best friend
into a quadriplegic
there was an affair going on the talk
was the most sexual
i've heard in an operating room he was
slurring a speech
have you ever been under the influence
of cocaine while taking care of a
patient
i take the fifth how many people do you
have to [ __ ]
how many people do you have to kill
the mistakes he made are mistakes most
surgeons never make
if you can believe it things get worse
you